les exigences de moscou n'ont pas été
entendus par washington et ses alliés
c'est le message lancé par le chef de la
diplomatie russe la tendance
positive mais ne m'a promis à ma peau me
relève macha chaude que président c'est
un nid de poule
daniel et nina senora stocks yves
michaud néraud d'arnaud génie 4 les
mobiles
la veille les états unis et l'otan sans
surprise rejeté la principale demande de
la russie la fin de la politique
d'élargissement de l'alliance atlantique
décision saluée par kiev en d'autres
termes moscou veut à tout prix éviter
que son voisin en deviennent membres un
jour
des russes et des ukrainiens qui se sont
retrouvés mercredi à paris discussions
au format normandie sous l'égide de la
france et de l'allemagne les deux
parties se sont réengagés à respecter le
cessez le feu en vigueur dans le donbass
à part ça peu de progrès rendez vous
désormais en février good news d'être
[Musique]
inquiet d'une possible escalade
militaire l'administration biden a
exhorté mercredi ses ressortissants à
envisager de partir maintenant d'ukraine
une discussion entre emmanuel macron et
vladimir poutine est elle prévue ce
vendredi